the II use open borders allows citizens
to travel from country to country with
ease but for the two million workers
posted in other European countries the
frontiers of fairness are not open to
everyone after a four year grind to
ensure that posted workers received the
same rights abroad as they do at home
the European Parliament is voting on new
rules to make sure they are better
protected if two colleagues work next to
one hour and the same company
there should be treated equally those
companies will want to play by the rules
should not face unfair competition in
addition to equal pay for equal work
host country labor laws will apply to
all European workers posted for more
than 18 months other changes to level
the employment playing field include
having travel and accommodation costs
covered by employers and not deducted
from employee pay s Khilafah New Heavies
de la nación de remuneration Bassel
marsala mínimo say or syllable new ski
so attache poker live a yearly salary
equity doula Memphis o su Harlem mu try
to prevent a so-called chained postings
used to skirt legislation the revised
rules would also apply to posted workers
sent by a temporary agency in cases that
involve a subcontractor member states
may also require that workers are paid
the same as the main contractor member
states will have two years to implement
the new legislation at home
[Music]